I have a friend and mentor who is known as
the Master of Segways. And so in this video,
I'm excited to share how he would change the
topic of conversation. Because oftentimes you
might be in a conversation and it's not... You're
not really feeling it. And you want to shift
topics. And it could be at a holiday with your
family talking about politics which you really
would like to avoid. Or it could just be at work
and you just need to steer a discussion so that
it's a more productive meeting. In this video,
I'm going to share a funny way from my mentor to
change the topic of conversation. I'm going
to share a clever way to change the topic of
conversation. And I'm going to share an honest way
to change the topic of conversation. Here we go.
Alright, if this happens to be the first time
that we're meeting in cyberspace, I'm Chad and
my partner and I wrote a book called Ask Powerful
Questions Create Conversations That Matter.
And so, while I have... I feel like I've learned
about 2% of what it takes to make meaningful
conversations happen to navigate difficult topics.
And while I have 98% to learn, I've got some stuff
that I think would be really useful for you and
which is why exactly why I've recorded this video.
And so funny way, funny way to change the
topic of conversation came from a good friend
and mentor Brenton who I worked with at an
organization called World in Conversation.
And in the group, what he would do as a way
of segwaying conversation, he had a formula.
And it was you just insert speaking of ___. And
you insert whatever the person was speaking about.
Let's talk about ___. Whatever he wanted
to talk about. So, speaking of politics,
who's hungry? Right? And so,
I ended up being though... And
there's no way that I can fully capture
the magic that he did it with. It was just
every single segway that he had was just
created a little bit of joy. But somehow,
it actually did work. So, even though it
was obviously abrupt and a bit crazy even
in the way that he segued by saying, "Speaking
of..." whatever we're talking about, "Let's talk
about ___." Insert something completely irrelevant
that he's changing the topic to. For some reason,
it worked. And so, I'd invite you to actually try
out that formula. Speaking of ____, let's talk
about ___. Or insert whatever it is that you want
to talk about at the end. So, speaking of is the
key phrase to tuck into your back pocket. Because
to change the topic completely out of the blue
feels really jarring. But when you reference
what's currently being talked about
and then offer the new topic, it doesn't feel like
such a far leap or jump. So, that's the funny way.
The clever way to change the topic of
conversation is to follow your curiosity. So,
conversation is exponential. And we forget that
sometimes. We think because we're talking about
one particular sort of umbrella topic that that's
the only... We're kind of stuck in that lane.
And yet, in conversation, no matter what anybody's
saying about whatever topic, you are learning tons
of different information, right? So, if you ask
me "Hey, Chad. What's the story of the ring on
your finger?" I might tell you about how I met
Kate and that entire story and development. Now,
in me telling you that, you would obviously
learn the facts that I shared with you. But
you'd also learn something about how I feel about
Kate based on the energy that I'm talking with.
You would learn a little bit about me and my
way of thinking from this. Even though I'm
not specifically talking about that. And so, the
clever way to change the topic of conversation is
to listen for what you're naturally curious about
and ask a question rooted in that curiosity to
guide the conversation that way. Because there's
plenty of data in the room to take a conversation
in any direction. And so, when I say conversations
exponential, let's say you learned... Somebody
said was talking for about a minute. Let's say
you learned 5 things. Each of those five things
could be a separate question. It could be turned
into a separate question and a separate path of
conversation. And so, if you want to change the
topic of conversation, if 3 of the things that
you learned were about that topic, don't ask about
those. Ask about the ones that were brought up in
the conversation but don't necessarily really
relate. Now, this is a bit of a passive way to
change the topic of conversation. So, you may
be met with some resistance from people saying,
"What do you mean like..." Like, "That's not what
we're talking about." And they might want to pull
you back into that current topic. And if that's
the case, if that happens, for me, the third
and probably the best way to change the topic of
conversation is the honest way. And the honest way
to change the topic of conversation is to point
out the elephant in the room and acknowledge
that whatever you're talking about right now is
not working or is not productive or is not what
you'd like to talk about. Or just state what it
is or why it is you'd like to change the topic of
conversation. And then do it. So, state what you'd
like... State why you would like to shift the
conversation by noticing the dynamic that's
currently present in the room. And then say,
"Let's talk about ___." Now, depending on the
group, depending on the context, you may want to
seek permission so to say, "Hey, I feel like we've
are talking about this a little bit in circles. We
only have 30 minutes with each other. Can we table
this right now and talk about ___ instead? Can we
table the discussion about the game last night and
talk about what we have to get done so that we can
end our meeting on time?" Do you see how in that
I point out the elephant in the room? I took a
break from the content of the conversation. And
I pointed out and accessed the process of the
conversation. And then I invited the group or
the person to come with me on that journey. So,
in order to really and deeply change the topic
of conversation, you've got to point out what's
currently happening and why that might not be
working for you. Let me give you one add-on tip
to the honest way to change a conversation.
And that is... Sometimes if you for whatever
reason you don't feel comfortable pointing out the
dynamic, pointing out the elephant in the room or
saying you don't want to talk about whatever is
currently being discussed, you can state your
intention really clearly for why and what you
want to change the topic to. So, for example,
let's say we were talking about lions but we
wanted to talk... I wanted to talk about zebras.
So, I'm using a generic example so that you
can insert your own dilemma here. So, if you're
watching this video because you really want to
figure out how to change the topic from politics
to what people are going to do next week, right?
You can fill in that blank. So, if we're talking
about lions and I want to talk about zebras, I
could say, "Hey, I think we've talked about lions
enough. I'm kind of done. Can we move on and chat
about zebras?" Or you could leave the lions out
of it and you could just say... If you're in the
middle of talking about lions, you could just say,
"Hey, I would love right now to shift the
conversation a little bit and talk about
zebras instead. Is everybody okay with that?"
Stating that intention might be enough. Now, if
you've got a particularly rebellious or resistant
group or a group that really likes lions and they
don't want to let go of the lions, what you might
do is state your intention to talk about zebras
really clearly framed a as a value to the group.
So, to say something like, "Hey, we've got limited
amount of time and I would love to connect more
with all of you so can we talk about zebras
instead? Can we make that shift?" So, you see
you're kind of framing the benefit of saying,
"Hey, I think this would be actually more
useful more productive to chat about this."
Now, in any of these strategies that I shared,
is it possible that somebody just says, "No, I'm
talking about lions. I'm going to continue to talk
about lions. You can't do anything about it. I'm
going to talk about lions." Yes, that is possible
and yet unlikely. Because we have a desire
to fit in and belong. And so, if there's enough of
a kind of even nonverbal consensus in the group of
like, "Yes, please change the topic from lions
to zebras. I'm so done with this." It's unlikely
that somebody is going to stand alone and fight
that for too long before saying, "Okay, fine."
And to go along with everything. Doesn't always
happen. Your scenario is going to be specific
to you. And there's no way that I can know that
or could know that at the time of recording this.
But I hope that the funny way, the clever
way, and the honest way to change the topic of
conversation were really useful to you. Tons more
resources. If you want a free excerpt of the book,
if you liked these cards, lions and zebras,
there's links to them in the description.
I exist on the planet to gently eradicate
small talk and create conversations that matter
which is why I spend a lot of time and investment
money to create these videos. Because I think
that life is too short to chat about stuff, we
don't want to chat about. Have an awesome day.